the Joe Rogan experience when you gave
me my purple belt I remember thinking
dad's probably one of the happiest
moments of my life because to me purple
belt was like a blue belt was like you
just kept showing up
you kept showing up you kept showing up
now you got a blue belt but a purple
belt was like you could get a black belt
you just have to keep going even the top
of the mount is a purple belt you're
right there we still we fought the top
prize there's no way down there is just
up you right there with all of them that
was during the fear factor days I was
more happy about getting that purple
belt than I was about getting fired I
have to mention some because I get a lot
of message from people that commented
you're hooking good in Jogja and you did
good say man come to my school anytime
Joe Hogan shows up and he's he's back
now training it's not about his power
man he doesn't care he wrestles
everybody anybody and I see him twisted
people around and in school and he's one
you know this is this is real he's one
of the hardest students training
partners that I have and I think one of
the last time I rest of him in my Malibu
school I think we trained maybe for half
an hour something like that I was there
for I don't know 20 minutes just trying
to sleep Joe and Joe is right there I
finished the training man my legs are
sore and I don't I don't remember if I
did sweep him or not - just stop
training after half an hour you know I
want people to understand it's anybody
that I wanna train I would never and I
refuse I never give a bell to anybody
unless they deserve the belt I wanna say
the service I don't defer people from
more famous less famous thought now it's
everybody's jiu-jitsu world is the same
you have to walk in the same road as
everybody because that's the only way
you actually want to learn jujitsu for
real yes you not remember you say no to
anybody training get hurt a lot of times
that don't care show up and my neck is
here my knees they're in training and
you're out there that you listen here's
what the strongest scuse my language
[ __ ] I have my school trainers
it's with
and that's why I'm here we I'm pushing
him to get back and I'm gonna show up
and now that I know where he is I'm
gonna show up here what's up Joe
as soon as I hear this [ __ ] it is
amazing and I want people to know that
is the real deal another thing that
people don't know is when he was back in
the fear factor time he had one idea -
one of the challenge for the people
would be training fighting a cage with
me in that case doing jiu-jitsu and they
didn't realize Joe you don't need me you
go there and do it yeah you're gonna
mangle everybody there you don't need
anybody to do that yeah we end up not
happening and they decided that it was
too dangerous to do a person versus a
person they thought that it was too many
legal implications exactly meanwhile
they have people ride a [ __ ] bull but
so the challenge was they were gonna
have to start with you on the ground
like in your guard or with you mounting
them we're gonna figure out what it was
and whoever survived the longest you
know like you don't need me you can use
Joe you're gonna do the same thing and
you're gonna twist whatever needs to do
it has all the tools for that
that was funny thing that the point was
you you can do it with no need for me to
do it